iris um this feels like a good time to
get into a little family business
considering you're promoting your family
business movie the bubble and i was
wondering if you would do a final five
family edition with me of course
[Applause]
that's right okay number one who is most
likely to forget their lines on set me
okay who is the funniest your sister
your mom or your dad who cracks you up
the most my sister
pretty funny okay who is most likely to
spill a secret
mod
[Laughter]
i call her the town yeller because she
literally tells everybody any
anything that i say to her which is you
know okay i love them um it also strikes
a good chord for sisterhood um who has
the biggest potty mouth of the family
my dad
yeah
okay
which parent is most likely to lay down
that law
my mom for sure she's
quite yeah she is
very she's strict when she needs to be
which and i definitely needed it at that
point like for sure
she's very strict but she she knows
exactly what she's talking about she's
always right so i
i definitely appreciate it i need it i
need it
i love you i love your family i'm so
happy for this really awesome fun movie
you can watch the bubble streaming on
netflix starting april 1st
and
i just i really i do i love you iris i
love your family and you've made the
world a better place
[Applause]
[Music]
you